So the key point to notice here--
and this is why the One-Time Pad provides perfect secrecy--
is that for any given ciphertext we can produce any message we want
by picking different keys.
That means that if we just have the ciphertext,
we haven't learned anything at all about the message.
The way to produce the message 'BS' from this ciphertext--
well, we just need to change this first letter to be one below
where C was.
So that means we want to change this bit
to be a 0 instead of a 1 in the output.
That means we need to flip one bit in the key.
So we'll need to change this key bit
to be a 1 instead of a 0.
Everything else will be the same.
This will change the output letter by one.
So if you guessed this key instead of the correct key,
we get what looks like a fairly reasonable message out
but it would be one off from the one that was there.
And--in fact, we could get any possible message we want
by guessing different keys.
So this is what's called a One-Time Pad,
and that notion of a One-Time Pad goes back until at least 1882.
It was discovered quite recently that it was known about this early.
There were One-Time Pads used in World War I,
and used in many other contexts since then.
The notion of the One-Time Pad being known this early
was only discovered last year by Steven Bellovin.
What made a One-Time Pad really interesting was the analysis
that Claude Shannon did.
Claude Shannon was the father of information theory.
He did some of the first theoretical work in cryptography.
During World War II, he studied communication,
and he also studied theory of secret systems,
and he wrote this paper, which was the first paper
that really understood in a theoretical way
what it means for a cipher to be good,
and this paper was written during World War II.
It was classified and released in 1949.
So what we're going to look at next is
how you formally reason about a cipher being secure
and why the One-Time Pad has all the security properties
that make it a perfect cipher.